بدون قدرة
المنظمات الإنسانية على الوصول إلى الأشخاص المحتاجين، فإن
الوضع كما قلت سوف
يتدهور بالنسبة لهم. نحن نعلم أن الناس
في حاجة ماسة إلى المياه، في
حاجة ماسة إلى الغذاء، في حاجة ماسة إلى كل تلك
الأشياء الأساسية
لبقائك على قيد الحياة.  ومع ذلك
تستمر الأزمة دون قدرتنا على الوصول
إليهم، لذا فإن الوضع سيئ كما
رأينا في أي مكان في العالم
ونعلم أنه في الأيام القادمة سيكون
أه مأساويًا جدًا للكثيرين أه الذين
نسمعهم  يعيش الناس على
لتر واحد من الماء يوميًا في بعض
الحالات أو يضطرون إلى غلي
مياه البحر من أجل
البقاء على قيد الحياة، وهذا سوف يزداد سوءًا
أه نحن نعلم ذلك أه المواقف في
العديد من هذه المراكز الجماعية  نحن في حالة
يائسة حقًا، كما تعلم أننا سمعنا
رقمًا في ذلك اليوم عن مرحاض واحد
لـ 10000 شخص، إنه من
غير المقبول أن يتم
وضع الناس في هذا الموقف، لذا فإن أي تطور
في الأزمة أو أي تفاقم للأزمة
هو أمر غير مقبول  لن يؤدي إلا إلى خلق المزيد
من الكارثة لما نراه للمدنيين
المتضررين